[Music]
PFT ot the extra show where we talk
about all the things we didn't get to
during our two hours of radio and TV
Chris you get to get everything you're
in you hear me I hear you see me I'm
good I see this yep but see what tell me
what you want to show me the finger I'm
gonna give you the fragrant always
blurred out all right we have some
things that we for the slow time that
there were plenty of topics we didn't
get to today and I want to start with dk
Metcalf a guy that you had pegged as a
first rounder in the 2019 draft I had
heard not long before the draft he may
last until round three and but for the
Seahawks trading up to get him at the
bottom around two he would have fallen
to Round three right Russell Wilson has
been raving about this guy and it feels
like it's more than just the perfunctory
Russell Wilson raves about everyone on
his team uh-huh routine
he's raved about him physically and now
Russell Wilson praising DK Metcalfe's
brain how he processes information how
quickly he understands he's really
intelligent he really understands -
understands the game and he takes
coaching well he puts in extra work he's
a legitimate pro receiver he's
everything that we expected him to be
and that is scary if he can deliver if
he can make a I don't I don't want to
invoke the names of any receivers who
have made a huge impact as a rookie in
the past that's not fair - DK Metcalf
but if he can make a big impact right
away this the Seahawks will look like
geniuses for making the move to get DK
Metcalf yeah I mean I almost feel like
this is gonna be one of those like duh
what was the rest of the NFL thinking to
pass him by two times I mean that's to
me I mean you know the guy that's 230
pounds and was the fastest guy in the
draft at you know four three speed and
was like the most explosive guy at the
combine and like every category what
he's good in football I mean you're
right you're hearing more than the
normal praise out of Seattle it's not
like oh yeah he's rookie he's working
hard he's doing good things though I've
seen a number of articles where it's
like whoa the guy stands out it's
special of course he does
you know I think the one thing that
concern teams was of course the the
injuries the neck injury the other thing
that concerned teams you know to me was
not a DK metcalfe problem it was an Ole
Miss problem that teams you know don't
evaluate the player the right way where
they go his route tree is not as good or
you know he didn't get a lot of
production yeah well you know he didn't
have a great offense the quarterback was
a little erratic I mean I really watched
old miss football games sometimes Mike
and I wrote this in my notes when I was
watching him and AJ Brown the other
receiver out of there where I went are
they trying to win the game are they
actually trying to lose here because it
was like they went out of their way not
to get their good players the football
so I'm not shocked by these developments
yeah and you know you talked about teams
that passed on DK Metcalfe the Giants
had three first-round picks they had to
pick at the top around three they could
have moved up if they wanted to to get
DK Metcalfe and the New York Giants a
team struggling to replace Odell Beckham
jr.
DK Metcalfe could have come in handy if
he if he is gonna come in and have a
huge impact and I mentioned the Giants
and their receivers because Giants
receiver Cody Latimer believes that the
team can have a dominant collection of
wide outs and dominant maybe a bit
strong especially because it implies
having a quarterback they can get you
the football but I look at the current
Giants receivers all due respect to Cody
Latimer and Golden Tate and Sterling
Shepherd but dominant is not the word
that comes to mind no I mean either you
know I'll say this I think they have
that they're skilled group has potential
their wide receiver room has some solid
players and has some question marks on
next a few players where we go he could
be something but we don't know yet it's
kind of an unproven commodity hey Golden
Tate sterling Shepherd hey they're good
we know that they're solid Evan Engram a
tight end
he's a special talents a qualm barkley
you got him but the big question I think
when you want to talk about dominant you
need somebody else there to go along
with that and yes Cody Latimer is he
gonna be that guy like a real threat in
that offense Corey Coleman
the ex first rounder out of Baylor that
was drafted by the Cleveland Browns it
has kind of been all over the place the
last few years you hear good things
about him as far as the the Giants and
offseason training so yeah I don't think
I'd go as far as DOM
yet but there's certainly potential
there and I think that the often says a
little more talent and then maybe we all
realize just just because I think we
think Odell's gone that it's not as good
yeah it's not as good but it's still
pretty darn good with some of the talent
guys they have there and here's the key
if they rely upon Seco on Berkeley the
way they should he will be dominant
which will make it easier for the
receivers to do what they need to do and
one of the big question marks who's
gonna be the starting quarterback for
the New York Giants will it be Eli
Manning week one will it be Daniel Jones
one will flip the Daniel Jones those
will be big factors in whether or not
the receivers play at a high level but
if they commit to running the offense
through sake while Barclays life gets a
lot easier yeah those receivers okay
they're gonna they're gonna have open
spaces down the field because the
safeties are gonna be doing everything
they can to get up there and clog the
lanes where say Quan Barkley will
otherwise be gashing opposing defenses
ah okay 100 percent go ahead you got any
of that you're right a hundred percent I
know the Giants are your favorite team I
just want to make sure I give you a
chance to talk about your your New York
Football Giants no I'm good they are my
favorite team but I'm good you hit it
all I just was agreeing with you all
right the Tennessee Titans have a
quarterback that they're not quite sure
whether he's going to be the quarterback
beyond this season 20 point eight
million in the fifth year option for
Marcus Mariota and John Robinson the
team's GM recently explained that they
are stressing Demario to the importance
of living to see another play avoiding
contact avoiding injury and it's a very
simple exercise in physics and biology
right you get hit a certain number of
times you're gonna get hurt it's it's
it's it's just basic statistics and
Marcus Mariota we have seen get injured
at inopportune times Blaine Gabbert gets
thrust into that week 17 playoff play in
game and the Titans lose to the Colts
and they don't make it to the postseason
so they are trying to get Mariota to
understand that it's important for him
to be able to play and it's amazing how
many quarterbacks are always on that
list whether it's new guys whether it's
older guys whether this guys like Carson
Wentz who are just still fairly early
into their career but they've been
around long enough they should know
better there's always gonna be those
guys that we talk about they'd say they
don't know how to keep themselves
healthy and you're not gonna see those
guys playing into the late 30s if they
don't know how to
keep themselves healthy and Marcus
mariota's chance to be a starting
quarterback is gonna hinge on his
ability to perform this year and one of
the big factors in that his ability
Chris to keep himself healthy which
means his ability to make those
decisions to throw the ball away to take
a sack by doing the old Peyton Manning
dive to the ground if you need to do
what you have to do to avoid getting hit
because that ensures you'll be able to
finish the game yeah and you'll be
available the next week the next week
the next week and so on yep you make all
the points I mean you you've heard me
say he's a he's a great athlete who
plays quarterback instead of a
quarterback who's a great athlete and I
think that's always sometimes those kind
of guys who have these issues too
because yea his athleticism his strength
his speed have always been so great that
he never had to worry about these things
Oh high school I'm just gonna run every
bye everybody you know it's the middle
linebacker I'll stiff on him and keep
running you know college football yeah
it's a notch up in competition from high
school but he was still elite there as
far as being able to run away from
people and maybe lower his shoulder and
you know hit a linebacker in the pac-10
who's 212 pounds and not as explosive as
you know some of the guys he's gonna see
in the AFC South but you know you get to
the NFL and things change and he has not
been able to yes just kind of find that
you know that brake pad to say okay I'm
gonna go down here it doesn't matter
about the three extra yards added to
that mic like you they're saying would
live to play another day not only the
unnecessary hits but how many times he's
tried to go a little bit farther and
fumbled the football or you know made a
mistake and being careless with the
football because of that too so he's got
to find that fine line of being able to
play and show his ability but not go
overboard to where his ability gets him
in danger and that's where yeah this is
the year if he doesn't figure it out
this year he's gonna be a backup
quarterback until he can prove himself
again and and look we all get evaluated
by someone there was someone out there
who is responsible for determining
whether or not we're doing what we are
supposed to do on the job and when the
GM of the team is telling you right
don't take the hit if you feel the
pocket coming down on you and you take
off running and the linebackers coming
off of coverage and he's screaming at
you throw the ball away it's okay to
punt the main thing is I'm stressing to
him and these are all comments to Albert
Brewer of si.com to
as best as possible like all
quarterbacks do to avoid getting hit so
if he doesn't avoid getting hit if he
doesn't do the things John Robinson
selling do he won't be the quarterback
next year it's that simple
no you're right he won't be that good
the quarterback they're gonna be losing
games or he's gonna prove again that
he's not capable of staying healthy or
taking care of the football
or doing things like that and that's
kind of been the issue with him
throughout of his career we've seen
moments where we go oh gosh he's got it
here we go Marcus Mariota is about to
take over and then as soon as we start
getting comfortable saying that he
either gets hurt or he puts a few games
together where we go damn how did he
miss all those throws this game or how
did he look like that so just needs to
be able to put it together in a bigger
body of work than he has in the past and
hoping he can do that this year we've
talked from time to time about coaching
candidates for the 2020 hiring cycle
it'll be here before we know it Lincoln
Riley the Oklahoma coach a guy who has
rebuffed NFL interest in the past came
out over the weekend and this is all
information becomes available because
Oklahoma University is a public
institution the full coaching contract
is available if you submit the public
records request to the right agency in
this case the Oklahoma University
athletic department produced the
contract and it shows that Lincoln Riley
has a buyout after this season of 4.6
million dollars if he goes to another
college program or to an NFL team and
Chris you know it sounds like a lot of
money and it is a lot of money but for
an NFL team that really wants Lincoln
Riley cost of doing business right they
buy out the former coach all the time
you pay a lot of money to get the guy
that you want and considering the fact
that NFL head coaches don't make nearly
as much as they should
what's an extra 4.6 million dollars to
get the guy that you want no you're
right it's chump change for an NFL owner
and an organization and all that so it's
nothing I mean I honestly that's I'm
with you Mike the first time I read this
I went ooh
4.6 million dollars that's gonna be
nothing if he ever wants to really make
the change and become a head coach in
the NFL you know hey last year if we
were talking about this I'd go who cares
this is crazy there's no way Lincoln
Riley should be going to the NFL as a
head coach he's a college coach and you
know I got to see more but now I feel
like of course with some of the hirings
we saw this year of course yeah I do I
think he's gonna be a candidate this
year
I think a lot of it though will be
predicated on how Kliff Kingsbury
success goes in Arizona if he's really
successful or shows that that offense is
exciting and he can develop calimary man
I think that's the demand for Lincoln
Riley will go will be that much you know
more great but if it's kind of a stinker
in Arizona then maybe people get cold
feet about the Lincoln Riley the whole
college you know great offensive mind
thing again and who knows where it goes
and that bio goes down to million
dollars a year by early 2022 it's
entirely gone where's the area where
here's here's what here's we have to
keep in mind yeah right
you've got to Lincoln Riley pupils now
in the NFL collar Murray in Arizona
Baker Mayfield in Cleveland now I don't
know how long Kliff Kingsbury is gonna
last in Arizona but Lincoln Riley and
Kyler Murray a potential match at some
point down the road
same thing in Cleveland if Freddie
kitchens can't get it done and a year
ago I've said this and I I hope for any
kitchens does well if I'd have made a
list of a hundred potential head
coaching candidates for the 2019 cycle
yeah last year I wouldn't put for any
kitchens on the list so if he can't get
it done and we've already heard Baker
Mayfield stump for Lincoln Reilly to
come to the NFL Lincoln rally could end
up in Cleveland as well so that it's
it's it just makes sense to keep an eye
on it whether it's four point six this
year three point six next year
eventually zero that draw is gonna be
there and you're right Chris the better
these these college quarterbacks who
played in the wide-open systems do the
better those systems translate to the
NFL the more attractive Lincoln Riley's
gonna be and you know maybe like Chip
Kelly was just a matter of time before
that jump happens yeah right I mean I
feel like it's like Baker Mayfield has
success to set up Kyle Emery to be the
number one pick right I don't think if
Baker Mayfield doesn't have a great year
last year I don't think Kyle Emery would
have been the number one pick Baker
Mayfield got everybody comfortable with
the shorter quarterback officially
finally it's all done I feel like it's
gonna be kind of the same story like
Kingsbury does good even Zack Taylor I'm
gonna throw them because they're just
these first-time offensive guru young
type of cubies QB you know mentor type
guys where yeah this that this shows
that it's successful then Lincoln Riley
is gonna be a hot commodity calimary was
the first pick in the 2019 draft second
pick was Nick Bosa and we knew this was
coming Chris we could sense it for weeks
and as it turns out Matt Miyoko of NBC
Sports Bay Area pointed out over the
weekend that the 49ers decided on Nick
Bose at the Scouting Combine and they
told Moses camp at the time he was going
to be the pick at number two so here's
the thing we saw three years ago Joey
Bosa holdout deep into training camp
almost through the entire preseason
because they were fighting over a couple
of factors that are relevant to that the
top contracts every year the cash flow
of the signing bonus whether or not the
guaranteed money's gonna have soft
offset language they fought about it he
held out they got it done now questions
are arising as to whether not Nick
Boesel will have a deal done in time for
training camp Chris if the 49ers knew in
February they wanted this guy I'd like
to think that they've accepted the fact
that they're gonna have to give him the
same kind of structure his brother got
at a minimum or they're gonna have to do
without him during training camp and the
preseason yeah and that's scary for a
guy who's you know again not played a
lot of football and had injury issues I
certainly would want him there for
training camp and that to me I have no
knowledge of this situation but you know
ok with the Joey Bosa situation it was
the Chargers not basically living up to
what you're supposed to do four top five
picks right and just as far as like some
of the money you're supposed to get the
guarantee money in the first two years
it's how quickly they pay out your
signing bonus the Chargers had a way of
doing it that allowed the money to stay
in their coffers longer than other teams
did it and the charger that the Chargers
came up against and an agent and a
player who said no we want a different
structure and they eventually found a
compromise but it's all look when you
draft Joey Bosa you don't necessarily
know what you're getting yourself into
from that perspective when you draft his
kid brother three years later and you
know what's happened with Joey and he's
represented by the same agents you're on
notice that these are issues so I you
know I'd like to think the 49ers have
have budgeted that reality into their
assessment of Bosa otherwise they're
gonna end up not having him for training
camp in the preseason just like the
Chargers didn't have Joey so they that
will say maybe it won't be an issue
there's no there's an injury provision
they're trying to put it in the contract
something along those lines because of a
guy who's just had hernia surgery and of
course
the training or OTAs and gets hurt again
are they but what can you put it I know
why not gonna do a split contract for up
the second of all pick in the draft I've
already thrown out yeah no yeah he's
gonna get thirty three and a half
million fully guaranteed over four years
the only things that really matter the
guaranteed money if he gets cut at some
point the next four years and he goes
somewhere else do the 49ers get credit
dollar for dollar for what he makes
elsewhere that offset language taking
the offset language out that's one of
the things you can negotiate and from
time to time we see a fight over that
and then it's the cash flow of the
signing bonus when do you get that bonus
because there's value in having money in
your account you can earn interest off
of that money you can do things with
that money so if the signing bonus is 15
million you want it all as soon as
possible you don't want five million now
five million six months from now and
five million a year after that you want
15 million within 30 days if you can get
it right so you can start with as a team
wants to get that that's you know yeah
that's that's oh you're right that's
what they want sorry yeah and so here's
the bottom line is this the 49ers knew
or should have known what they were
getting into with Nick Bosa because
there's no reason to think he'll
approach this any differently than his
brother Joey did so we'll see how much
they factored that into their planning
of preparation but if there's a holdout
they can't act surprised right
especially if if the terms of the and
that's all it would be its cash flow on
the signing bonus or its guarantee
offsets there isn't much else there
isn't anything else that you can fight
about with those top picks it's also
formulaic at this point you almost don't
even need an agent for that rest right
no you don't you don't need an agent
they kind of write themselves so yeah I
mean I'm surprised to hear about this
too I didn't really catch win to this
until you know what late last night
really when I when I kind of just was
flipping through all kinds of news I
didn't realize this was really a ongoing
thing so I will be surprised or
interested to see how it all unfolds and
yeah I mean well I I just I'm shocked
that we're at this point but really with
the 49ers yeah right still plenty of
time to get it done before the start of
training camp if they get it done it
won't matter but there's reason if
you're a 49ers fan or just paying
attention what's happening the NFL to
watch that number two spot because so
many
guys are currently son these deals are
easily done caller Murray's deals done
right these deals are easy to do but but
what happens is you get agents and
players who want to dig in on these
issues it's their opportunity to kind of
stand up to the Machine and that's what
Joey Bosa did and I think Nick Bosa
probably wired the same way same agents
it's just something to keep an eye on
and chris mentioned flipping through the
news I hope he was doing that at pro
football talk.com all right you to do
the same thing all day long wins the
next Chris Simms unbuttoned we would
tomorrow tomorrow afternoon it'll be out
more on the quarterback countdown coming
up Kurt Warner gonna be a guest nope
absolutely not we better we can find
better no no we're kidding
we love Kurt listen we love her Warner
because he interacts with a lot of the
things we put into Twitter during the
shootout about Hall of Fame quarterback
one of the great stories of all time no
I'm gonna say to clarify what I just
said I'm just mad that Kurt Kurt and I'm
not like mad mad I'm mad that Kurt tried
to imply that I did this was doing four
clicks okay I'll try to imply it he said
it he said it so that was a low blow so
I'm allowed to throw a few low blows at
him to then just he lowered the belt
level and that's just where it is right
now I'm sorry all right well I I I got
nothing personal I'm cool with Kurt it's
all good I got nothing more to say all
right sometimes the best thing to say is
nothing at all we'll see everybody back
here again on Tuesday have a great
Monday Chris great work as always
PFT live tomorrow PF t OT p f TP and
we're gonna have a Markku Perron PFT
p.m. today will get updated Oh miss
Kanye yeah there you go
you're kinda sit yeah well not really
but I'm sure I asked a bunch of stupid
questions but maybe there'll be at least
one in there that gives us some
information about his contract status
and how he feels about the Cowboys vs.
playing on the Raiders that and more
check us out all day long all night long
a pro football TOCOM have a great day
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports